in spring green wisconsin there is a
house
on a rock
but
it is so much more than that
inside it is home to many bizarre and
incredible collections
there's a room of self-playing
instruments
an infinity room
a giant squid attacking a whale
and some nightmare inducing dolls
it seems like a really strange museum
and that's because
no
it appears to be a museum because it is
housing antiques it's housing all kinds
of memorabilia and things from a
different era
it's more of a place to just enjoy so
what is house on the rock
the house on the rock to me is a magical
complex it's an all-around sensory
explosion
it was made by alex jordan who was an
architect not at all not at all he is
not a trained man he's just a man of
great vision maybe not an architect but
an evident hoarder alex jordan with the
help of his friends built the house on
the rock in the 40s and opened it to the
public in the 60s
his collections of antiques and junk new
items and old
real and quite obviously fake have no
central theme or apparent reason for
being there and maybe that's part of its
charm
there are some pretty incredible things
including a huge unrideable carousel
269 different animals not one of them is
a horse
really yes the horses adorn the walls
of course they do
you know every time you turn the corner
here it's a different thing and it's a
different wow and
you don't know what to expect
one man's trash is another man's
roadside tourist attraction